[Music]
assalamualaikum
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
t3m podcast
it's your host fayad with rami and angel
how's it going guys
yeah so this is episode one officially
on the youtube podcast
in episode 999 of our usual cause
uh looking forward to uh spreading some
truth insha allah
so to begin a question i have for you
guys is
why why do you live the way you live
because generally we always know that
okay i'm doing this like we know the who
what where
and when right i'm doing this i know who
i am
i know how i'm doing it i know what i'm
doing i know when i'm doing it
but we don't exactly know why so
generally one question
i have for you guys and everybody is why
do you live the way you live and how
do you know that is correct because had
you grown up in another country with
different views
on very specific issues you would also
have those same views and if you were to
take you from
america for example and you from a tribe
in
i don't know deep within some cultural
african area and you were to compare the
two they would highly disagree on many
topics so
why do you guys think you live the way
you live
i don't know take it away
well i'm gonna say that it's largely due
to
our upbringing and our environment
because bro we are we are a product of
our our nurturing our nature
and you know most people will say ah um
i am the way that i am or this is why i
do this
but it's like that's not really them
that's just their nurturing their nature
and they wouldn't really know
why or they wouldn't really know who
they really are unless they took that
time out to themselves
and they just kind of disconnected from
everything and just reconnected with god
i agree it's so much easier to become
like your surroundings
and be an agreeable person instead of
standing out
and once you get into that slippery
slope it's easier to maintain something
which is like inertia instead of
changing who you are
taking the time to fix up bad habits
things you want to improve on
and become a newer version of yourself
yeah okay i'm in full agreement with
that
because with a lot of people like you
guys mentioned they're a product of
their surroundings right
they grow up a very specific way and i
would say that
they're just a version of themselves
like i mentioned in that
comparison in the beginning the same
person in two different places
they would be two different people
ultimately but they're the same person
in terms of you know every everything
else right who what where when
it's just like their morals and why they
believe what they believe
that's the only thing that has changed
so
now the question is how do you know what
what's right how do you know that you're
right because there is basically moral
objectivity
which objective truths
and then there's moral subjectivity
which is i believe this i believe that
with my limited bias and information and
so on and so forth
so how would you guys kind of
approach this topic of how do you know
you're living the correct way how do you
go about living the correct way
well how would you see that um
all right well pull a question back on
me sick
i would say that moral objectivity can
only come from
a creator like being a godlike being
because every single human being
is limited in information and they have
a bias regardless everybody has some
kind of bias whether they admit it or
not
whether it's large or small everybody
has a bias and everybody's definitely
limited
with their information so to get an
objective truth you would have to know
everything
who's the only one that knows everything
allah
god the creator so if you want objective
truths especially with something like
morality
because if i if someone asks me to prove
that murder is wrong
how do i prove that it's wrong i can
prove it doesn't help society
i could prove that we would see it as a
barbaric thing but to prove it is
wrong you can't prove that so that's
where
subjectivity comes in for you
if you really think about it like
subjective morality is just based on
feelings
what feels right what feels wrong
inherently
to add to your point when you look at
murder
it occurs in nature right every day we
don't
look at it and say okay wow like there's
something wrong with that
but when it's with humans we have that
sense of okay right and wrong
where does that come from but there's
other things that
do occur in nature which also occur in
socialization in humans
but we think it's okay too right so
you're right
yeah just uh just uh kind of uh back up
the point there
when it comes to uh something like
murder it's funny because
you'll have the people that say if you
kill any living being you're a murderer
right but then when they want to protect
themselves from covet 19 so they put
hand sanitizer on and they kill all the
living bacteria on their hand
they would never call themselves a
murderer for that right so it's kind of
funny when you're dealing with moral
subjectivity they always have these
general rules like don't murder
anything that that's living and they
kill all the bacteria and all of a
sudden they're a murderer by their own
standards and then when you bring that
to them they're like wait no
so it's this is the issue with not
having all the information but making a
judgment
and this goes for everything in life
right but speak on morality specifically
uh
thanks but i would go as far as to say
that
us knowing uh like what's right and
what's wrong like that stems
from our fitrah and like y'all know what
the fitra is it's that
and they believe in that right they're
the creator bro so it's like
if you take away everything if you strip
away everything like i was saying
in my previous answer like you are left
with that fitra
and like that's where you know what's
true and like what's not true what's
right and what's not wrong because
you are guided by something bigger than
yourself
yeah that's facts that's facts um i
would say
after that um before you go on so
yeah we talked about subjective and
objective but i guess the viewers want
to know what's wrong with subjective
morality
you know what's wrong with just going
based off your feelings and instincts
before we talk about the problem we got
to realize we got to identify in the
grand scheme of things how it's
maladaptive how it's non-resourceful you
think of subjective morality you think
of it in the grand scheme
it's always changing see people if you
really think about it
the slave enslaving of you know african
americans
was subjectively morally considered okay
back then a couple you know 100 years
later
or you know decades later they realized
okay it's not okay
which you know i agree with it's not
okay but the thing with subjective
morality is
you're wavering your beliefs you can go
back and forth if the people in power
and control
deem something to be okay one day it'll
be okay one day
if five years later they realize it's
not it's not
and you kind of have to conform to that
group thinking
and follow that school of thought
there's no guideline and backbone
in what is right what is wrong
yeah subhanallah and that's actually uh
what i was just gonna
kind of dip into like the issue with it
because when we have something like
our innate belief and instinct and all
of that
this works generally but not everybody
listens to it
right and some people become so
misguided that that becomes clouded in a
sense
and this is the people that allah
basically left astray so you'll have
people
who could be mentally ill and they could
want to murder and that could be a
instinctive kind of oh i feel that i
want to commit murder right i really
want to do this thing
and that might feel right to them but
then you have people that are like no
that's
under no circumstance is okay and so not
only do you have changing beliefs over
time
and over place you have two people in
the same exact room that group the same
exact way and mom will say abortion is
wrong
and the other will say abortion is right
how do you prove who is right who is
wrong
you cannot prove that you can argue that
okay giving birth to this baby
would be detrimental one to the baby to
the to the um
the mother so on and so forth you could
say but you're murdering an innocent
life and so on and so forth it's no
longer your life it's a child's life now
and you can take sides you know however
you choose but there's no way to prove
it
so objective truth must come from a
creator
and that would just be through religion
ultimately x
x it's the guidelines all right let me
play let me play devil's advocate for
one question
because i know a lot of people might
have this question how do you know
what objective truth is
all right so objective we're speaking as
subjective beings
all right all right so are you talking
about a
a religious person or a religious person
why not both
all right so from a religious standpoint
they would just follow the religion that
they
believe in right the religion they look
at they say this is the truth
and you know emphasis on the truth
meaning it's from god they would see
this and say
the guidelines that come with this
religion the moral guidelines and
etiquettes that come from this religion
these are objectively true christians
will say this about their religion
muslims will definitely say this about
islam we look at islam and things like
if you kill one soul one innocent soul
it's as if you killed all of mankind and
then we have rulings that constitute who
is an innocent person who is not an
innocent person
when it's okay when it's completely
haram so on and so forth so a muslim
will look at that and say
this is objectively true the quran and
the prophet peace be upon him say this
and that
therefore they say we hear
and we obey right but a subjective
person
with no religious views or values will
look and say
i feel and i obey and then the next
person beside them will say i feel and i
obey
and then you have contradiction but when
you have a majority of people on the
same page when it comes to religious
views
that is what we would identify as
objectively true from god as
objective morality and you guys already
know where the
where the saying uh uh if you kill one
man
um it's as if you killed all of mankind
um it came from the crown but you guys
know the story right
i don't know all right let me let me
remind you so you know what adam peace
be upon him he had two kids right
able and at least yet his two first sons
abel and king
so i believe that he gave them both um
some some type of test and i
i believe it was able that passed the
test
and he was he was given the blessings
but cain wasn't
and because cain wasn't given that he
he had that spite in his heart and he
killed his brother
and it was at that time it was the first
time that murder took place and unjust
anything unjust it was i think the first
sin that occurred
in this dunya in earth and that's when
allah said
um if you kill one man it's as if you've
killed all of mankind
yeah subhanallah remember from i
actually i didn't i didn't know that
that was the story associated with it
um this was actually in like the full
version of quran while allah mentions is
that
for this reason i forgot what the reason
was but allah says for this reason we
ordained upon the children of israel
that if you kill one soul it's as if you
killed all mankind if you save one souls
as if you saved all mankind
and uh this is because some people
mention that it's in like some of the
jewish scriptures that exact verse and
people say we stole it but the quran
mentions it as well just getting it out
there but yeah subhanallah
it's um it's amazing from the from the
get-go
allah set that in place because it to us
it would be it would seem like such a
fundamental thing
like murder is wrong right and
i'm sure um actually i believe there's
narrations
uh talking about he kind of felt a bit
guilty afterwards or he didn't really
know what to do and then allah
sent crows where one killed another and
then buried him to show him that he
should bury his brother afterwards
subhanallah
but this is how allah guides us right
this is allah showing us the best way to
live and
it's not just with morality right it's
not just with beliefs it's with
actions as well which is what i was
going to get into next
it's not just how do you know your
beliefs are correct right we're not
talking about cognitive dissonance where
you believe one thing and you do another
and then become depressed
we're now we're talking about believing
in a certain thing and now you're living
in a certain way
right you're not just saying this is
true this is moral
but now you're living in that way
because now
you're opening up a whole new spectrum
of the physical world
that can take good or bad physical
manifestations
for example i could choose that drinking
is okay therefore i will drink
and then i could harden myself or i
could say fasting is
obligatory therefore i will fast and
then i go i undergo all the healthy
benefits of fasting
so what do you guys think about that
well before before we even answer that
ramen could you
more simply explain objective morality
and subjective morality because you did
a great job explaining it but i feel
like for people who are watching
this podcast and
who don't i don't know and i'm trying to
put myself in their shoes and
the way that you explained it was it was
great but it was a little complex
could you put it in a more simpler way
all right inshallah i'll try so first i
want to give an example
an objective truth is something
that is true no matter what for example
one plus one equals two you may you
actually would have trouble proving that
one plus one equals two but you know
fundamentally
objectively it is true you can go to
mars it would be true
you can go to any part of the world you
can go under the ocean you can go in the
sky it would be true no matter what
any part of the galaxy universe one plus
one will always be two
right but then you have things
that this is subjective morality you
have things that
i feel i believe that this
is okay this is not okay and this is
something that no one can prove
right this is something that is not
objectively fundamentally true
right so if someone comes and says
something like
well i think abortion is fine why
wouldn't it be
you may not be able to prove that
it's wrong to tell that person no you're
wrong abortions wrong but they wouldn't
be able to prove that it's right either
so then you have this dispute when one
side cannot prove the other side or
wrong
because there's no fundamental basis
there's no rule book that they have
so what religion is it's that rule book
with the one plus one equals to it's
telling us
what is true what is false so we have
that objective
this is true point to make
so just to summarize it yeah let you
finish
just to summarize it object objectivity
objective truth is something like one
plus one equals two and subjective truth
is well
i think this i think that and you can't
really prove it
or proof against it and the beauty with
religion
and especially islam is the quran gives
you the scope of interpretation
or inference so it helps you strengthen
your iman or belief
so things like where you were saying
that oh uh
we have this this ruling this guidebook
on this is right this is wrong
oftentimes sometimes it leaves it at
that but other times it also explains
why
and the times it doesn't explain why you
can put two and two together and come to
a conclusion why it's right or wrong
but the times it explains why it just it
tells you just like that
yeah it's a panel just to add to that
actually
in islam you very rarely have
a rule that is consistent no matter what
for example
the one one of the rules that would be
consistent no matter what is
you worship one god alone part of me you
worship one god alone
with no parties no associates nothing
right no matter what
even if you're dying you still work you
still do that even if you're living your
life you still do that but something
like
eating pork it's haram but if you're you
know starving in the middle of the
desert or in the middle of nowhere and
all there is
is pork to eat you're actually obligated
to eat that pork
you're not allowed to say it's haram i'm
gonna die you're obligated now to eat
that pork
so this is the beauty of islam because
everything is situational
and this is something the scholars go in
depth on in a variety of uh
moral views and and rulings islamic
rulings for example the pig
example i just gave because if they had
said that okay no you must starve and
die
how is that beneficial because above not
eating pork is maintaining your life
and your livelihood so i think that's
the real beauty of the
objective moral views in islam
i was well put by the way simplifying it
fire go ahead and answer the other
question if you remember
if not then let me by all means
reiterate yourself
take it away
he's on a roll man let him shine wait no
yeah
it's a conversation it's not election no
no i'm i'm saying like
if you remember what fire was saying
before i had
interrupted and had asked him to uh just
put
the objective and subjective into a more
simple term
he has said something prior to that do
you remember that
i don't what was it
i have no idea either no
hopefully we'll find our way back to
that at that point but um
actually i mentioned before i had
mentioned uh actions
right in comparison to to moral views
right because you could have
a moral view that manifests itself
physically like i mentioned
i think drinking is okay and then i go
and drink because of that
or i think fasting is obligatory i must
do it therefore i fast and i get the
benefits of fasting
so would you guys like to kind of back
that up or give your thoughts on
how important it is to have moral views
that manifest physically
or otherwise
okay saw you brother
i'm gonna let you go bro hey romney by
the way that was what you said
yeah so you haven't you haven't been
speaking from
who you i'm just listening man
i'm one of the viewers right now
i mean okay what would you say angel
what would you say
um one of the the bigger things
islam has done for you because if for
those of you who don't know our brother
anahan here may allah bless him reverted
very very recently
so he wasn't a muslim until a few weeks
ago may allah bless him
but um so what would you say without
getting into you know vast detail
some of the greater impacts islam has
had on you spiritually
morally or otherwise yo
to facilitate it then versus no
thank you all right so uh very simply
put
before islam i was constantly trying
to find my way i was trying to find
uh peace and i was doing everything
possible that you could think of i mean
i
had been to therapists i have been a
psychologist
i have done tons of meditation i have
been
uh catholicism christianism
if that's how you say it christian
christianism um
was atheists for a while then i went
into the whole new age thing
and guys the only way that i can put it
is that
islam was just like all right here it is
like here's the path
this is what you do and as long as you
do it
you're good and i find that most of the
things that i was doing before like some
of them
are still beneficial like meditation i
still do it every now and then just so i
could be more aware of what's going on
in my head
uh kosha was for sure no fat for sure
but nofap is already in islam
like that's something that it's already
practiced like you're not supposed to do
it so
it's like i was already doing something
that was in islam itself
but um
when i got into islam it just made it
very simple for me it gave me
it gave me a path and my grandfather
used to always tell me he's like
uh when you buy a new phone it comes
with instruction manuals just like
bro fire remember we were talking you
had said that
when you get up that frame from ikea it
gives you the uh
the instruction manual on how to build
that bed frame and it's like you could
build the bed frame by yourself without
the instruction manual
it's just going to take you a lot longer
you got to figure it out for yourself
but if you have the instruction manual
right there why not
use it and finish it in a fraction of
the
time and do it perfectly because you
have the instruction manual
right and that's that's what islam has
done honestly that's what islam has done
so alhamdulillah yeah that guy building
the bed frame might get frustrated and
think
you're saying it might take him longer
to get to that point where he he
finishes building the bed
yeah what if he doesn't what if he's
part way through he just gets so
frustrated he thinks there's a problem
with the bed
which is effects a lot of religious and
you know woke spiritual
but a religious people saying oh you
know why do
good things happen to bad people why do
bad things happen good people and they
just
a lot of things just don't click whereas
if you had the instruction manual
you don't understand where where things
are going
now go ahead go ahead i was just going
to add on to that because i find it kind
of funny to be honest what if he puts
the bed together incorrectly and then
after a few months it breaks down
subhanallah although it's
objectively incorrect subhanallah
right yo so like romney says i'm gonna
piggyback
off what both of y'all said
i want to say a few years ago uh when i
was my ex
she had gotten a new bed frame from ikea
all right so it's funny that we're
talking about this from ikea and
man this was one of those like stupidly
complex bed frames i'm not talking about
the simple ones this is the one that had
like the drawers underneath
i don't know what they were trying to do
with this but me
being the hard-headed stubborn person
that i was
i grabbed the instruction manual i tore
it up
and i said all right we're going to do
this without any instruction manual
and we spent literally six hours
six hours trying to make this thing and
when we finally got it
i was just like why did i do that why
did i tear up the instruction manual
and try to do this by myself when it
took me six hours
and like y'all said i could have messed
it up we could have messed it up
but like referring it into a real life
scenario aside from the example
it's like dude i was doing all these
things before i came on
islam i was doing all these things
before i had the instruction manual
and like i didn't know if i was going
left if i was going right i was going
forward if i was going backwards
i was just trying to be
at peace i was trying to be happy i was
trying to
uh i don't know i was trying to find
something greater to life like
a greater meaning or something and it's
like dude like like you said i may have
never
found that you know or maybe i would
have but maybe i would have
found it out figured it out maybe like
at the end of my life
where it's like now dude i'm 26 years
old and alhamdulillah like i found it
i wouldn't even say i found it i was led
to it
so yo two things i want to add to that
one
bro the fact that it took you six hours
to build an ikea
furniture piece without achilles
manual i think that's impressive bro
because i think ikea's
instructional manuals are just on some
next
whatever so sometimes it takes people
including myself
six to eight hours to build it with the
so that's commendable bro that it took
you six hours i think that's an
achievement
number two you said you were led to
islam what do you think
because i know a lot of viewers are
gonna have a question about that what do
you mean led to
don't you are we individuals aren't we
leading our lives
what is what is the whole thing about
let go and like god what does it really
mean
all right so i'm uh i'm gonna try to
explain this as simple as possible and i
i'll try not to take too much time here
all right so
when what it means to let go and let god
is that you know ultimately we have our
own decision we can decide anything we
want in this life
right you wake up you can decide whether
you're going to brush your teeth
whether you're not going to brush your
teeth now obviously if you don't brush
your teeth
you're pretty nasty all right but
you have the choice you can brush them
you cannot brush them now
yes you have a decision and that's what
you would refer to as free will but you
got to understand like
this is all a test this is
all like a game and when you play a
video game
you you start playing this video game
it's already been programmed
by something it's it was created by
something
right so the video game is the creation
you are in this creation you are part of
the creation or technically you know
you're playing it
and you can choose whatever you want in
this game you can choose to
let's say you have this person in front
of you you can choose to help them
or you can choose to kill them and rob
them all right like
whatever choice you make the game is
still going to unravel
and go off in that direction and that's
how life is so like whatever choice you
make
that's what's gonna happen in your life
and what it means to
let go and let god is to basically
quit trying to control everything
quit trying to uh for lack of better
words be god
you know it was like you started
thinking to yourself ah well i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna do that
my life is gonna go in this direction
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this i'm gonna be
making this much money i'm gonna meet
with this woman over here i'm gonna have
these kids i'm gonna leave this legacy
i'm gonna do all this
but it's like at that point like you're
just
trying to play god and it's funny
because like before i got into islam
there was a song about travis scott
saying stop trying to be god but um to
get back on point right
mercury you're letting go so you stop
trying to control everything
and then once you stop trying to control
everything
and you disconnect yourself from
everything that's that's when god comes
in
and it's like all right cool
let me help you out you know i see
i see that you just you just let go you
just
took a a step aside let me let me step
in now now that you want to step aside
and um i'll share my story if y'all want
but
let me not take this spot like y'all go
ahead
subhanallah bro that was that was
amazing allah bless you
but um there's a few things i want to
piggyback off that point
so uh subhan allah actually what came to
mind when he said that
was the verse in the quran allah says
have you seen the one who has taken his
own desires
as his own god subhanallah and that
that's exactly kind of what you were
talking about right
and what i see is a person in the person
you described right letting go and
kind of not taking charge anymore and
letting god do the work
this is the person who has submitted to
allah this is the person who has become
humble
i i know i realize now this bed is too
hard for me to put together
i'm going to leave it up to allah and
then that's when allah guides who he
wills right
when allah says that he guides who he
wills it's not just like okay you get
guided and
no you don't get guided and there's no
reason for it it's because some people
are humble
and grateful and ready to submit and
some people are just arrogant like
like how many signs came to him right
literal miracles
so allah used one of the miracles to
destroy him and that was the end of him
and he tried to cry at the end of his
life he tried to say you know
okay i believe in the god of moses and
it was too late for him it was too late
he died
in that bad state so subhanallah that's
what i see a person who became
who submitted to allah and that's what
everybody should be because that's
you know our fitrah that's how we're
created so i wanted to quickly
kind of bring it back to the point but
first i want to talk about
this idea of determinism which is
everything is going to happen the way it
is and it's everything is predetermined
and that's it
which you can't deny that everything
only happens once you can't go back in
time everything's determined
right but there's also this idea of free
will
you cannot deny free will either right i
feel anyone who says i only have free
will there's no determinism
this person is kind of illogical right
and somebody who says there's only
determinism no one has free will
it may be a little more logical but it's
still illogical because we're still
consciously choosing
what we're doing right so
one philosopher said that free will and
determinism
are two trains that are perfectly in
sync
and moving perfectly simultaneously
together like you said it's programmed
no matter what you choose to do
it's so programmed to happen a certain
way now
with the analogy of building the ikea
bed frame right
often in physics and in math and in any
complex
uh language or science big
problems are just a bunch of small
problems right so think about the bed
you're not taking one half and two half
or one half the other half and then
pushing them together you're taking all
these individual little pieces
little problems and putting them
together and if that's difficult to not
take
six hours and it's physically something
you can see imagine something as complex
as life
where you can't even see all the
implications of it you cannot even
see what's going on in your own self
even science to a certain extent can't
see what's going on within your own self
we can only see to a certain point right
now think about morals
that are unprovable but yet undeniable
at the same time
how can you how do you go about
something like that you cannot put that
together therefore you need
and that's why i wanted to tie it back
to you need objective truth
if you believe in morality otherwise
morality is not something that exists to
you because you cannot prove it
so i think subhanallah we've done an
amazing job of just showing how
necessary religion god and objective
morality
is because without it what are we we're
honestly we're no different from animals
living by our desires and that's
basically it
you guys take it away man that's that's
actually beautiful and that's why
you know that's why in the quran we
believe that you know allah gave
us free will and he didn't he didn't
give the angels free will
that's why if we do good alhamdulillah
we're better than the angels
because allah gave the angels
intellect in terms of like commandments
but no free will no
instinct right so he gave us
he gave us like both but allah gave the
angels only
commandments intellect and all that so
who knows if they would have had the
instinct
or those desires maybe they wouldn't be
all that they are that's why we would be
deemed better than them
if we're good people compare that to
like animals and and primitive you know
what you see in nature allah gave
animals only instinct only drive only
desire
no intellect that's why if we're you
know subpar if we're not on point
we might be worse than the animals
because had they have had the intellect
and and the commandments and the true
guidance
maybe they'd be better than us
dude and i just i want to add to this
like a lot of people they might be
seeing it and they might think to
themselves well
i i like god's who he was
okay but how do you know if you're being
guided how do you know if you're not
being guided well
here's the thing i'm gonna go as far as
to say that
we're all being guided and it's
your choice whether you wake up to that
or not
you know like i i am not god i cannot
say
hey this is your sign this is what
you're supposed to do in your life
but like i can't say from my own
experience that
like the signs are everywhere and like
in the quran it even says like
if you are a believer you will see the
signs everywhere look for the signs
and you will find them and that's
like if someone wants to see like oh
well how how can i be guided would just
take a step back bro um
subhanallah bro it's about allah that's
true that's so true
uh there was something i was going to
mention based on that point it's kind of
kind of set my
my mind now so if anyone wants to take
over go ahead but um
again devil's advocate question for you
i hear this a lot with people that are
anti-religion or just irreligious they
ask
and they always say that they have this
objective
sense of morality without god what do
you say to that because they're going
around saying that oh
you know all these things that god is
telling you are right and wrong
i already innately feel that or they
claim i subjectively feel that
why do i need it that is god
if you're feeling something that's
directly aligned with like the objective
morality that is god working through you
and giving you
like literally giving you that insight
because that's not something that you
can find yourself and if you believe it
is then
you're ignorant because bro how often is
our mind
going from one thing to the next
like our mind is constantly changing bro
if i talk to you
in 10 years you'll probably be a
different fight yet
rami will probably be a different romney
like y'all will think differently now
of course y'all will still be on the
straight path
because y'all are a muslim but if you
talk to someone who has
who's completely secular who's
completely let's say agnostic or
completely
uh atheist or new age whatever it is
that they want to say they are
their mind is going to change so much
within those 10 years
that it's like what was once
truth to them 10 years ago is now not
truth
10 years later subhan allah that's true
and i imagine we undergo another like
scientific revolution where everything
like science just flips on itself
subhanallah dude yeah
but subhanallah uh what was gonna say
about
objective and subjective morality with
with all due respect
to everybody if any subjective person
comes and say i have objective truth
because i think this and that they've
contradicted themselves and i don't
think any logical person would make that
claim
i believe that if a person actually
knows what objective truth or
objectivity versus subjectivity is they
would never make such a
idiotic statement but uh
yeah so i would say for a person who
wants to be guided because sometimes you
know i feel this is right
and then i feel that is right and they
could be two contradictory things so how
do you know which one's actually right
um or two different people that feel two
different things how do you know who is
right
i would say that to a certain extent yes
allah put the fitrah in us
but it's not a quran it is not the quran
or the prophet
all of islam internalized within us the
prophet
said about him that his character who he
was
is the quran period that's who he was
always right
we are not like that we're not even
close to that and that's fine
so allah gave us logic and rationality
so if you have something like a religion
that is rationally and logically true
and you cannot think of any possible and
not even you cannot think of no one
it's completely incoherent or
inconceivable that they would know these
things 1400 years ago in the middle of
the desert
or amanda cannot read or write would
produce such an amazing book
linguistically speaking to the point
where even today it is still taught in
schools as the fundamental
basis for the arabic language right
peace be upon him
and he had prophecies and miracles and
so on and so forth
gandhi wrote it by him um a bunch of
people a bunch of
even oprah winfrey talked about islam
right a bunch of people talking about
this religion this man named muhammad
peace be upon him 1400 years later
the most um the most popular name in the
world
right so on and so forth if you cannot
find a reason
to disbelieve in this religion logically
rationally it is
coherent it is it must be correct if
there is a god
why would he allow another religion
that's more true than his that doesn't
make sense so the most
religion must be from god so this is how
you are guided by wanting to be guided
and by seeking it out right allah in the
essence of trusting in god and this can
apply for anybody
but the essence of trusting in god is
the hadith where a man came to the
prophet
peace be upon him and he said do i tie
my camel
so it doesn't leave or do i trust in
allah and he said tie your camel
and trust in allah do what you need to
do and trust that allah is going to
guide you and help you and have it work
out in the best way
so that's why there are two extremes of
just doing what you need to do and
saying i don't i don't trust god's going
to help
like atheists or the fully spiritual
people that are like
god the universe whatever suffolk will
guide me i'm not going to do anything
they're going to sit at home in iraq i
wasn't beneficial
i'll give you a more applicable uh
application for someone like me who's
currently a student and i know a lot of
people watching are in school right now
and they could relate to this
how how foolish is it to just you know
not study
and be like all right god got my back
yeah god got your back but
maybe not always in the way that you
want him to have your back so you can't
be out here like oh i want to get that
hundred percent
inshallah i got that 100 percent i'll
make dua together 100 and you not study
all right and if you just keep studying
and you just only rely on yourself
there's a lot of things out of your
control that you're not going to
understand
yeah and that's bro that's where like it
all ties in
where it's like you need the instruction
manual
you need the guidelines you need to let
go you need
to let go and let god do its thing
because
i'm gonna put it in a very very simple
example visual because i'm a visual
person
all right give me one second i'm gonna
flip this camera over
make some space here
all right so let's say
that that's a straight path all right
you have fitra you understand things
because god is giving you that insight
now
let's say you don't believe in god at
all let's say you know what
this is my life i'm the one that chooses
everything that i'm gonna do in my life
and that's that right this is you
you you may be just sporadically or
maybe just
out of nowhere you might have some
insight that is directly aligned with
the objective morality with the st with
the truth
all right so you're walking the straight
path but if you do not have instruction
manual if you do not have guidelines
this is what's going to happen you're
going to go off and then maybe
maybe you might make it better and then
if you might make it back you might be
there for just a little bit longer and
then up you're off again and who knows
you might never go back to the straight
path
and it's as simple as that
and the entire distance that you're
doing you know you're doing too much g
like it's so much easier to just go
straight
yep yeah subhan allah let's say the uh
the quickest path is just a straight
line right
but um yeah it's amazing analogy may
allah bless you
and i quickly wanted to add in every
time you you went from the straight path
and you diverged off all i
saw was the person who's letting their
emotions get in the way
logically coherently they have no reason
right reason is very important
like the why right there is no why when
it comes to trading off the path there's
no reason to do it
so it's only a an emotional thing so
when people
let emotional skepticism like we talked
about get in the way
of oh how could you know god allow this
to happen
that's just emotional because you don't
know why it happened you don't know all
the implications of it you don't know
the logic behind it let's say an entire
nation goes through a very difficult
time
but that difficult time makes very
strong people
and then it actually betters a nation in
the long run was that necessarily bad
and if you if you believe it was immoral
you'd have to prove that but
again subject to morality wouldn't be
able to but
my point is emotional skepticism is is
very detrimental to a lot of people and
living
in this age this is why i wanted to to
talk about this topic
because living in this age it's the age
of emotional skepticism
nobody knows why anymore no they just
kind of
feel and then go off those feelings and
the issue with that is
many issues to be honest actually i'm
going to let you piggyback off that
because i know you guys probably have a
lot to say on that
it's fine let me go in real quick so
what you're saying here actually dude
by all means go ahead my my training
thought just completely left me bro
no man i had nothing specifically to say
to that i was just gonna
once we're done with this introduce that
where are we going with this because i'm
sure a lot of people are wondering like
okay we talked about this
some some of the demographic they're
over here like okay i don't believe in
god
um i believe in whatever i can see
whatever i can guarantee
there's another demographic that's like
okay i don't believe in god but i don't
not believe in god
and then there's obviously people that
are like okay i believe in god
but they're almost ignorant it's almost
like you're muslim by nature
or or by name you're christian by name
but you never took the time to like
question everything then allah says in
the quran that you know
don't just take the religion of your
fathers because it was the religion of
your fathers
and he's talking to us muslims too like
i was muslim by name by by birth
most of my life but it's not until
recently that i became a believer
right so this is the third category and
then the fourth category is
i would say not majority of the muslims
i would say
you know definitely it's it's not
majority as much as i want it to be
are the ones that truly took the time to
like understand that okay
this is it why it's it and why there's
nothing like that so
again we're gonna talk about you know a
lot about establishing islam
um talking about different religions you
know here and there
um and in detail in another episode but
i wanted to
get us to establish why god because we
are talking about morality
subjective objective but where does god
come into this why god
why is there why is it necessary to have
a god
oh bro i think it's super necessary
because like we were stating but like
everything that we've spoken about
up until this point all right and
aside from that i remember what i was
going to say to romney's question
earlier which
i'll put that aside for now and if i
come back to it i'll come back to it
inshallah
but everything that we said bro
you you can stumble on to the straight
path
but how long will you be on that
straight path if
you don't have any guidelines that's the
real question right and
that's that answers the why that answers
the the question
why god why have an instruction manual
why have the guidelines
it's because everybody wants to be at
peace
everybody wants to live the best life
that they can live everybody wants to be
happy everyone wants to
just enjoy life like look at little kids
like
they're all joyful they're all innocent
they're all just trying to
experience life they're not uh burdened
with
everything that we are now that we're
coming on to this adulthood
so it's like bro that's the answer if
you want the answer it's very simple
it's right there the kids
have the answer the way that the kids
live you know not saying that adults
should live like kids because we have
responsibilities but
just see it for what it is like they're
innocent they're pure
they're just experiencing life and that
is the straight path and
that's why that's why you need god
that's why
you need an instruction manual because
if not bro if not bro
you are just swayed by your emotions
you're swayed by your thoughts you're
swayed by your environment the people
who you hang out with
and like i said you might be on the
straight path but for how long
yeah subhanallah that's very true
nothing wrong with
being you know having emotions and you
know a lot of people are going to come
at us
there's nothing wrong with having
emotions without emotion
we wouldn't be who we are we wouldn't be
human beings without emotions we
wouldn't have survived because the whole
reason you know
our adaptive you know selective value of
emotions was
fight or flight survival or or not
survival right so we need
emotions today and we needed that once
upon a time there's nothing wrong with
that what's what's problematic is when
we always rely on
emotions to lead us in right or wrong to
lead us in everyday life and make
decisions for us yeah
because they're temporary yeah subhan
allah
they fluctuate a lot that's the real
issue uh they fluctuate
basically every every few minutes sabana
lower every few seconds actually
this panel of very very good points i
guess to summarize
the point you were making on hell is
kind of like because
we need guidance basically right if we
don't have guidance we don't know where
we're going we're not going the right
way
therefore we need guidance and if it's
going to be objectively true the only
one who knows everything is god so if
there and there's this is a big if for a
lot of people if there is a proper way
to live
if there is guidance only god can give
it to you that's why god is
the only topic of this conversation when
it comes to objective morality
and now for the people that are like i
don't know if god exists
do you guys want to get into the whole
contingency argument proof reason for
god's existence if you want to save that
all right okay i'm the love that you
know i'm glad you brought that up bro
i think that from where we all sit
you know the three of us
but as a trinity because here's where i
think we should go with that i think we
should
set aside a whole separate episode on
establishing why islam i want us to talk
about briefly
other religions but why you know
allah or the islamic god is decod
that's that's like another episode this
episode let's do what you said
let's establish you know briefly in in
in
relatively you know sufficient detail
why allah or why at least god
has to exist why there can't can't just
be you know
all of this happening at random yep
okay and um just to throw it in there
because i know if i don't say it i'm
gonna forget it
but uh to answer the question you were
referring to before
about like people doing this and that
but then like you know late later on
like
it's different you know they're swayed
by the emotions like that the thing that
i want to share with you all is um
y'all know that quote where it's like
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards
and well that's that applies a hundred
percent to this where it's like
the only person who can connect the dots
looking forward
is the creator we are just
the creation and right now we are in the
dark
and if no one believes that or if some
people don't believe that like
bro tell me what happened before you
came into this world tell me what
happened before you were born tell me
what
what's gonna happen when you die if you
can't answer that then you are in the
dark
and bro like if you're in the dark i
know
you know damn well you can't you don't
you can't distinguish what's
what's straight what's left what's right
you're just moving around
blind you just you can't see anything
and
that is dude that's what god is man god
is the light god is the light that's
just gonna bring you to the straight
path like hey just
go this way your your uh
you won't fall on that couch you won't
hit this tv over here
you won't fall into this hole um you
won't get this girl pregnant over here
and pay uh child support like you're
good you know what i mean but it's like
you won't know that if you're trying to
do it all on your own and the thing is
we were never meant to do it on our own
yeah it's been a lot very good point
masha'allah it's a great point
so kind of to summarize it a few
questions because i want to leave
all us all of us and everyone watching
with a few things inshaallah a few
reflective points firstly i want to ask
everyone
why do you live the way you live all
your morals take every single one of
them or the important ones right
abortion murder family values whatever
it is right take all of them
and if you believe in a religion ask
yourself why do i believe in this
religion even if you're muslim
ask yourself that and do some research
insha'allah we'll talk about it in
coming episodes
and if you don't have a religion but you
have moral views which everybody does
prove them to yourself prove them to
anyone prove that your views are correct
or that they're right
because if you can't do this then why do
you believe in it and we're tying it
back to the main question of
why because everyone knows the who the
what the where the when
they don't exactly know why so why do
you believe in what you believe in how
do you know it's true
and if you can't prove that then you're
in a bit of a sticky situation to put it
lightly
so yeah what do you guys think about
uh those reflective points there how
would you guys summarize those
i would go as far as to say that um
that is that is it
that is a hundred percent it's like you
have to
you have to understand what your why is
and you can't be emotional about it you
got to be able to set your emotions
aside because like
you know we were talking about this
earlier yesterday when we were talking
about the cognitive dissonance and we're
joking about putting that into the uh
channel intro but that's that's exactly
what it is it's cognitive dissonance
when
when you believe something and it's so
ingrained into you
but it's it's just something that was
given to you it's something that like
you kind of just grew up with it's not
something that you
you sought out for yourself you seeked
it for yourself it's not something that
you would lead to it's just something
that was there it's like
you know i was born into uh catholicism
for the most part and i believed that
for a while
i believe that for a while but it's like
i never went out of my way to question
why i believe that i just believed it
and then when people started like
throwing all these uh
these uh i'd say questions and
objections at me
i buckled i buckled because i didn't i
didn't know why
i didn't know why i was a catholic all i
could say
well i i did it because my parents did
it and i just grew up with it but then
it's like once i
started looking for the answers myself
once i put the emotions aside i said
all right well why is it that they said
this
let me look into this is this true is
this not true and it's like
the more that i went into it that led me
away
from subjective
morality and ultimately it led me to
objective morality but it was a long
journey
but not even to get into that i'm just
saying like
you have to know your why and you got to
be able to put the emotions aside
you do man another good way to put
subjective morality for people that
still can't grasp it in in how we are
uh holding it relevant to what we're
talking about is blind faith
a lot of people just have blind faith
and it's just a mission man
what's what's what really gets to me and
it saddens me is that
you have found you've questioned your
religion you've questioned everything
and you've come to see islam as the
truth
but there's a large percentage of muslim
you know guys and girls growing up if
you ask them period point blank why do
you believe in
you know islam oh it's just because my
parents put it on me you know
that's sad man
yeah subhan allah that that's very true
and it's very unfortunate
uh because if they were to read their
own holy scripture they would find that
allah like you mentioned before allah
does not want this for us
allah doesn't want us to go offline
faith the fitzra yes it's there
but it's only there to a certain extent
what comes after is what
allah has provided for us both within
ourselves and externally the signs the
quran the
islam as a whole the sunnah of the
prophet and our intellect
our rationality our proper ways of
thinking
so subhanallah i think it's it's crucial
that everybody
you know takes a good look at their life
and why they live the way they live it
especially i'd say especially if they're
muslim
because islam i would say is we would
all say is the truth
objectively is the truth it's even
provable to a certain extent that it's
the truth right using different
arguments that we'll get into inshallah
later on
but um yeah so i think it's highly
crucial everybody takes a good look at
their life
i had a point that i wanted to mention
but it kind of set my mind so why do you
guys take it away uh
keep that keep that thought don't loop
in the back of your head if it comes
back it comes back insha'allah
um let's move forward so without keeping
the viewers waiting
all right why god why is it necessary
you know why believe in god what is what
is proof that god exists
because you know we're living in a
society where there's people that are
atheists agnostic born in different
religions
uh they're just they're just they're
drawn at the question like why
how do we believe in god isn't it such a
leap of faith
to believe in god and i invite you guys
um you know you guys are going to hear
this and it's going to sound you know
crazy to somebody all but
it's actually a leap of faith to not
believe in god knowing what we know
and we don't even know something so like
out there and
you know where it's like secret or
anything like that no it's
simple very easy to understand and
inshallah
why don't you uh build the foundation
for this are we talking about the fine
tuning
all the fine tuning contingencies oh
okay some kind of lobsters
all right so basically
just to start it off this is what's
called a deductive argument
and a deductive argument is something
like one plus one equals two
it uses set premises general facts that
are true
like one being one and one plus one
equaling two and so on and so forth
it uses premises that are true and sound
logic proper logic to come to a
conclusion
so the the best example i can give is
the one i've been giving 1 plus 1 equals
2. that uses premises and logic to come
to a conclusion
and this is indisputable these are just
generally accepted facts
anywhere you are in the universe so this
keep in mind throughout this entire
discussion that this is the argument
that or this is the formula we're using
so we know that we exist we know that
other things around us exist
and from everything we can observe about
the universe we come to find that it
only exists
because something before it allows it to
exist
or something that exists at the same
time allows it to exist
for example without food nutrition we
cannot exist
right that's something that exists at
our time that we need to exist at the
same time
our parents without our parents existing
we could not exist
because they are necessary for our
existence but they are not the necessary
existence because they also come
from somebody else their parents they
also rely on food
and drink and so on and so forth now
forget people and animals let's look at
the
planets the galaxies or the universe as
a whole
basic uh scientific
belief i'll say because science is kind
of belief in a sense
just using uh induction or evidences is
the big bang model the big bang theory
or we basically know the big bang
happened at this point
and what we find the big bang is that
the universe actually came into
existence at one point
making everything in the universe also
what we would call a
possible existence
sorry can you guys hear me mm-hmm it cut
off for a second
so the universe and everything in it is
what we would call it impossible
just apology right there for people that
haven't grasped that yet
um just because i don't want anyone to
lose this when we when we get the ball
rolling and we get that momentum
the universe has a beginning because
it's expanded
and you can't expand out of you know
expansion it needs to have started
somewhere
so scientists cosmologists in fact it
all started
you know whatever years ago and that's
the beginning so the universe had a
beginning that's what we established for
sure
yeah carry on yeah may love bless you
for that
so so yes what we understand is that the
universe had a beginning it had a point
where it started and that's what the big
bang is it
just kind of sprung into existence to
use a physicist's
terms it sprung into existence right so
what we know is that it started at one
point so what caused it to start
right and i don't want to get this is
not the calam cosmological argument that
everything that exists has a uh has a
beginning everything
or sorry everything that exists as a
cause and so on and so forth right
so what this argument again keep in mind
is a deductive argument so
we cannot have and keep this in mind
this is the big point
we cannot have an infinite chain an
infinite regression
of things coming from other things for
example
your your mom came from her mom who came
from her mom who came from her mom
you cannot have an infinite chain of
parents
giving birth and the reason for this is
i'll summarize with this analogy if you
wanted to walk to the local coffee shop
you wanted to walk from your place to
local coffee shop but the distance
was an infinite distance right you have
to walk an infinite amount of distance
to get to the coffee shop
how long would it take for you to get to
the coffee shop how long would it take
for you to walk across that infinite
distance
you'd never get there you would never
get there or take you an infinite amount
of time to get there so the fact that we
exist
and we can observe that we exist it's
proof that
it's not an infinite chain going back
it's not an infinite regression
which means that there could be billions
of them but it starts at one point
and this one point must be the opposite
of a possible existence
because if it also comes from something
else or exists because of something else
then it's not
necessary it is not the starting point
it starts because of something else
therefore there is one beginning and
this beginning
must be the opposite of a possible
existence so it must be
something that is unlimited it is not
temporary it is not finite right it's
infinite
it's unlimited it's not dependent it's
independent
it does not need anything from anyone it
doesn't need
anything from anything it can exist just
by itself
by necessity it's um is not comprised or
built of any smaller parts because if
it's built of smaller parts
then it's coming from something and one
of the smaller parts or the smaller part
that would be the necessary existence
so if you look at what we're describing
infinite
independent uh self-sufficient we're
basically describing a god-like figure
already and this is a deductive argument
and this is something that's quite
indisputable
at this point if you what's what's the
type of argument bro
for those of y'all that that are just
wondering
did i say argument he's just he already
explained it bro
yeah great i'll give you an inductive
argument
inductive or inductive yeah okay yeah so
an inductive argument is basically this
every let's say we're talking about
sheep like the animals every single
sheep
right all of them every single one i've
ever seen in my life has been white
therefore every single sheep in the
world is white
that's inductive until you finally find
a brown or black sheep then you're like
okay
well most of them are white but there
are a few black that's induction and the
problem with this is it's based on new
information this is
all of science right the theory of
gravity
the isaac newton sir isaac newton had
back
a long time ago this changed when new
information was brought forth and a new
theory was brought forth because the new
information
in the time of einstein right but back
then
isaac newton's idea of gravity was true
that's what people believed and then
upon new information this happened it
was happening with evolution as well by
the way
even richard dawkins quickly on the side
no because we're speaking i guess the
atheists here
richard dawkins said in in one of his
books i forgot the title but he says
that
the darwini darwinism or darwinism or
dominance i'm sorry i listened to a lot
of uk speakers they speak
off but darwinism he says that the
theory of evolution
is going to be masked over with a new
theory or a change beyond recognition in
the few years i think 2021 is what he
mentioned
so even evolution in our understanding
of it and the mechanisms and the
theories
are changing as well so that cannot be
fundamentally true that's a problem the
problem with induction but some people
would say that's what makes it beautiful
that we don't certainly know anything
and it keeps us going
so that's what induction is so deductive
is something that is true no matter what
like one plus one equals two so
we know that everything in the universe
including the universe itself is
possible
indepe sorry it's dependent it's finite
it's temporary it comes from something
else it relies on something else
it cannot be the necessary existence we
know that's the first premise second
premise we cannot have an infinite
regression an infinite chain going back
because then we would never exist we do
exist therefore it starts at one point
this one point must be the opposite of a
possible existence independent infinite
unlimited uh self-sufficient doesn't
need anything from anyone and we could
take it a step further
we could say that this necessary
existence
since it does not need anything but we
exist
it decided it willed that we would exist
therefore we exist because it has some
kind of will or nature or something of
the sort
something that does not make it
dependent like dependent on its nature
or something like that
it there are certain necessary qualities
it has but it's not dependent or moved
by anything
right now we're describing god even more
we can take it a step further
right we experience good we experience
bad therefore it has some kind of
balance between the two
not every person experiences good that
every person experiences only bad
but there's a fluctuation so there is
some kind of order it has this only one
with one will
and it's not changing because everything
the laws of physics everything has
stayed in motion
and we know this because we have
subjectively previous memories we have
uh even documentation evidence is proofs
that
um certain laws have remained consistent
to our history as far back as we could
see and
to the point where i could say that if i
drop this it's going to fall based on
previous experience
and it falls every single time so from
this we can already
we're already describing god in a
nutshell right and to bring it to islam
ultimately would be the surah the very
beautiful
short surah in the quran the chapter in
the quran i believe it's 111
where it says allah the one
the one and only means that there's one
without any other basically
allah who suffered allah the
self-sufficient and a summit means the
one who does not need anything
from anyone but everything that exists
ultimately relies on him
that's what it means so say is god the
one god is self-sufficient
he does not beget nor was he begotten he
does not have a biological nature
in which he kind of relies on or
something where he can give
uh offspring or anything of the matter
because that's a byproduct of
us possible existences god does not have
biology
and he does not come from anyone he does
not come from a parent because then the
parent would be the necessary existence
it omits that thought process already
um and this is one of the main points
they're all main points but this is
astonishing specifically and there is
nothing in existence there's nothing
that is even comparable to him
meaning that everything that exists
possible existence cannot be compared to
the necessary existence subhan allah and
this came what
1400 years ago from a man who cannot
read him right in the middle of the
desert not a philosopher or anything of
the matter
the prophet muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him you can i challenge
everybody
to take a look at this and try and
criticize it and try and poke holes in
it dm me dm anybody
here if you'd like with your questions
or inquiries about it
but this is basically undisputable why
because it's a deductive argument
it's almost like trying to say one plus
one does not equal two and i'm sorry if
you say that then
you're gonna have to admit that's at
least incoherent or illogical
so i hope that was clear uh but yeah you
guys want to leave me back let me
let me chime in here and say that if any
of y'all are gonna dm one of us
to ask us questions about that dm romney
cause
i'm still new um i mean you could you
could dm five as well
i'm sure he he has a lot more knowledge
and more wisdom than i do on this
but even then bro i'm like eons and
bleems behind
rami when it comes to things like
cosmology and
you know the theology of islam
philosophy he's the one-stop shop like
you can come to me and i'll be like all
right i'll get back to you i'll think
about it i'll i'll give you the right
answer but romney has it ready
guys if y'all are watching uh we have
three forms of uh
transmission here uh my base is in
the whole secular because i've been in
that for a very long time
rami is in the islam and then fired is
like the bridge
between the secular and the islam
because he was born muslim so he always
had that
in his life but he was also in the
secular life
because he did not fully believe until
recently so
just so you guys know like when we speak
our perspectives that's where it's
coming from
and yes
do you want to do you want to define
what secular means or secularism
uh from what i
from what i looked up the other days
y'all were saying that i i had come from
like a secular
place i was like wait what does secular
mean i looked it up secular means that
you have beliefs
and views that aren't uh basically
aren't religious or
[Music]
they don't pertain to like a certain set
principles
so it's like i would even go as far as
to say like
new age people are secular because
they're taking
their teachings from a lot of places not
just from one place
and it's like at the end that you can't
really do that you can't pick and choose
like
the guidelines are the guidelines and it
took me years to figure that out
it's about a lot i agree man it's like
it's like saying okay i like
the steps one to 59 for the bed frame
and then right at step 60 it says
you need to use this and put that part
there it's like nah bro i like
i'm gonna try that and it's like okay
you could do that but
at the end of the day you're not going
to get the bend yeah subhan allah and
actually just to use that analogy one
more time
for myself let's say you you couldn't
figure out the bed frame you couldn't
get it to work
you as a person as a purchaser as a
consumer you just can't get it to work
who would be
the absolute forget the instruction
manual who would be the absolute best
person to contact about building this
bed frame
the creator of the bear frame am i right
yes exactly the one who made it he made
it he knows everything about he knows
he can probably do it blindfolded
because he created it so
if we have questions about life who
would be the best person to contact
about that
the one who created life and allah and
allah says in the quran
he is the one who created death and who
created life he knows the ins and outs
of both because he created them so if
you want to know what
what you should do in life with the best
way to live is you must go to the
creator
the one who made life in death the one
who made you and if you want to know
what happens after death you would have
to go to the one who make who created
death you cannot ask a death a death a
dead person
what death is like you know you can try
but one dutch
and two you're not going to get a
response to allah
so you'd have to go to the quran and the
sunnah i agree man it's too simple to
just
you know to believe in you know the
commandments and the guidance because
while you know it'll be too chaotic
otherwise you might think i
this step tells you to do this i don't
really agree another person might
agree with it but kind of another person
might completely agree with it and then
because that person agrees with it
the people they're talking to and the
people that trust him the new age people
whatever you want to say
they'll be like all right you know what
that kind of makes sense i kind of see
why
that step might not be necessary
now you're making your home you bet it's
not even the same yeah yeah
it's um you gotta have that trust
you gotta you gotta go to dios and
that's that's god i mean
anyone who's watching this i want y'all
to understand like
god god can be translated in many
different languages there's like many
different
names quote unquote but it's still just
one you know it's still just one god
and you yeah like i said you can't
you can't pick and choose the guidelines
it's it's already there
you you just have to you got to see it
for what it is
for like a better words you got to see
it for what it is
you have anything else for the huge
gold nugget of wisdom that you dropped
on these people
yeah that was it was big man and and i
urge anyone
rewind it once rewind it a thousand
times if it doesn't make sense
still reach out to one of us reach out
to romney um but i i
i'm confident that it'll make more sense
than you guys at least thought it was
and if it sparks up some new ideas
instead on that let it let it
let it marinate you know meditate on
that and just
just go deeper and don't resist it yeah
subhan allah one thing i want to mention
it's not really much of an argument it's
just kind of a
reflective thought right what do we call
the greatest uh philosophers throughout
history
we call them the biggest or the greatest
thinkers right because they
think right and they think about these
complex or very um amazing or
enlightening ideas
right to to say the least right
so this there's no shame in thinking or
pondering or reflecting or questioning
your own beliefs actually
think about it like this this is all
science is right if you think about it
if you're a believer in science this is
all science is
science can never prove anything right
but it can prove what's
wrong right so if you question your own
beliefs you're going to filter out what
is wrong what cannot be right
for example if you believe there are
multiple gods who are both all-powerful
this is not something that is possible
because neither of them are all powerful
if they're both all-powerful what if one
overtakes the other then
it doesn't make any sense right
therefore deductively speaking
there must only be one who is
all-powerful right so
this this is the essence of pondering
thinking reflecting questioning your own
views there's no shame in it
i think all three of us do this all the
time and i feel like everybody does it
um it's just a matter of do they
actually let it manifest or do they
brush it aside and ignore it
and become like those who are deaf dumb
and blind and just choose not to see the
signs because allah says in the quran
that yes there are signs out in the
world that you should go out and see
but there are also signs within your own
self
subhan allah and that's amazing
dude like
man i keep losing my train of thought go
ahead if i yet
no i have nothing for now
i've been talking too much man all right
you know what
because because we talked about you know
why god
i'm i'm sure people now at least if
they're not fully there they they
understand that okay
there has to be a god right to believe
that
you know in the fine tuning argument too
um
which was pretty much the the
probability that you know the world and
the the universe the dunya whatever you
want to say
is the exact same way as it is right now
as into sustained life you know humans
whatever you want to say
just to be order the probability of that
was so insignificantly low
so incremental like i'm talking like
it's so small
that every other probability
wouldn't have deemed you know life to
exist and what we have today
right so i'm sure mommy will explain
this in a more comprehensive you know
easier to digest way
but it's just there's there's numbers
like these these are physicists have
come with these there's like i think six
different numbers
in this formula and they're all like
huge so it's like the lottery of the
lottery
i kid you not and the chance of
then it's just this one way of all the
numbers to come together
and if it hadn't been this had been any
other different way
had the lottery drawn out any other
number we wouldn't have life
at all so this is the only number
this is the only way the only
probability that life
would have exist everything in this
dunya would be the way it is
and would you look at that that's
exactly what happened so just
looking at it and before romney goes you
know explains it properly
the the probability of it occurring at
random
i'm talking about this number that was
the number the
just believing in in that happening at
random it's foolish
it makes no sense statistically uh
mathematically whatever you want to say
to to believe that okay there was a
creator that sought out and
it it you know willed for this to exist
and it ordained for it to exist takes
less faith than to just believe this
happened at random
yeah subhanallah i mean firstly you did
an amazing job of explaining it
masha'allah
um don't worry but um uh there's not
much i can add to that to be honest um
i can give a few examples firstly the uh
the book
there's an uh astrophysicist and
cosmologist i forgot his name but he
wrote the book
i think it's titled the seven or
something like that and it talks about
seven
very specific numbers that form the
universe and one example that's often
given is the number for fusion
which creates uh which basically um
well i don't want to talk about things
i'm not too sure of but uh
so i'll just say what what uh what i've
read basically
the number for fusion is 0.7 or 0.0 yeah
0.7
as far as i know and if this number was
off by 110
if it was 0.6 we would not have the
universe in the way we have it and if it
was a little too high 0.8
then we would not have hydrogen and
hydrogen makes up i believe
70 of everything in the universe and 90
of the atoms so it's panel log this is
profound this is amazing
right and this is just one number out of
seven so basically what this
cosmologist and astrophysicist did is he
looked at these numbers and he evaluated
them and he
wrote a book on it i believe titled the
seven but muhammad hijabi he gave an
example
of if you were to take a bunch of
letters like abcd all the way to that
you take a bunch of them
and you put you cut them up and you put
them in a bag and then you shake the bag
and then they throw it into the street
and the letters fall down in a way that
forms one of shakespeare's plays
right like romeo and juliet or something
informs one of shakespeare's plays
the chances of that happening are more
probable or more likely
than the chances of the big bang
happening randomly and we get the
perfect
perfect universe we have today well
actually it is perfect i'm not expo
quotations the perfect universe we have
today
and the exact way we have it that's how
insignificant the probability is
of us having this universe in this way
so essentially what we're getting at
is the universe was finely tuned and
this is actually
a scientific term it's called the fine
tuning of the universe the universe was
finely tuned
to go off in this exact way
so fine tuning or a design if you will
entails someone who tuned it or
something that designed it
so it takes more faith
to be an atheist and disbelieve in a
designer
then it it takes more faith to
disbelieve in this designer than to
believe him because the probability
speaks for itself
it's so insa i like it it's smarter for
me to buy
one lottery and believe i'm gonna win
so imagine putting your life in your
afterlife on
these low this is this low probability
i'm sorry it makes no sense
yeah dude let me let me piggyback off
that
and let me just say that dude
atheism because i was in it for a while
let's be honest anyone who is atheist i
don't care what you guys say
you might say otherwise to what i'm
about to say
but i was atheist so i know exactly what
i'm speaking of here
when you are atheist you believe in
facts you believe in logic you believe
in science which is cool there's nothing
wrong with that
you know rama even said the quran tells
you
to seek the answers like go go for
yourself go out there and
test it or whatever it is but it's like
science is only going to
uh assure you of the answer
you see science is we'll say two steps
behind
meaning that like once science figures
something out doesn't mean that it just
came into existence it means that it was
already there but now science is like ah
we can prove that it's real that it
exists
so you know what it may never get to the
point where
it proves god's existence but would you
would you even need that when it's
already starting to prove
so many other things that are being
shown are being shown
in the instruction manual and then the
last thing that i want to say is that
when i was atheist
like dude i was not happy i was the most
miserable that i had ever been in my
life
and i was seeking
through all the external things some
form of happiness some form of peace
because i remember that i actually
became atheist
because my my sister's son he had passed
away at six months old
and you know for someone who believed in
god at the time and then
seeing something like that happen like i
just completely questioned
everything i said how could how could
you take away
a little baby at six months you're six
months old
and everyone's saying that all like
there's a reason there's a reason
i couldn't see the reason so for that i
became atheist
and it's like yes i got deep into
science yes i got deep into
these facts and all these other things
and i tried to argue with people who did
believe in god and all this stuff but
it's like
at the end of the day it was
it was pointless it was pointless you
know to to put it in
very simple words it was pointless to
not believe in god and it actually took
more effort to not believe in god
because
we all have fitra we all have that inner
belief
in the creator every single little kid
has fitra
and it's like dude every little kid also
has a very strong belief
in almost anything as well it's like
little kids believe in santa claus
little kids believe
in the easter bunny and it's like dude
once you found out that the
santa claus and the easter bunny wasn't
real because uh you could definitely see
a few stuff you can
do the uh the science and all that stuff
and show that easter bunny
and santa claus aren't real but it's
like
you can't do that you can't disprove
that god is not real
no what do you what do you mean it's not
real bro what
santa claus you know yo chill chill
bro so keep this all right keep this
you get hurt because you find out that
santa claus and the easter bunny aren't
real
and i know y'all can remember this i
know anyone who's watching this can
remember
when they were a kid and they found out
that santa claus wasn't real because i
know when i found that out it's like a
part of me was broken bro
cause i had been laying cookies out and
milk for this fat
dude for years and then come to find out
he was never coming bro it was probably
my mom's
or my dad over here eating the cookies
and
drinking the milk all right so once i
found out
i was hurt but it's like i got past that
and then what i'm trying to say here
what i'm trying to like bring with all
this
is that when you're atheist it's the
equivalent of you
being that hurt kid that found out
that um santa claus and the easter bunny
wasn't real and it's like
you're holding on to this idea you're
holding on to this victim car that no
god is not real god is not real when
it's like
dude the signs are all around you the
science doesn't disprove
that god is real or not so
like are you really gonna keep holding
on to this card
that's making you miserable that's
making you
uh seek happiness and do all these
things to
just try to be at ease try to be at
peace
so that's that's why i'm piggybacking
off romney where it's like
yeah it takes way more to be atheist
than it does to be uh a believer
subhan allah um you touching a really
important point there
um there are a few actions masha allah
like the
the problem of pain and suffering in the
world right
because islamically we would look at
that you know six month year old baby
and we would say that okay this baby is
going to heaven
because this baby didn't even reach the
point of uh puberty where you know a
person's actually starting to get sins
for what they do it's an innocent baby
goes to jannah goes to heaven but uh to
a
disbeliever or someone who doesn't have
that particular belief this could cause
a lot of issue and i know with people
like bart ehrman
who's the scholar of the new testament
he has a problem with uh you know pain
and suffering the world and he
disbelieves in god for that reason
but the problem with that is in my
humble opinion the problem with that is
you don't know all the implications of
that particular thing to be able to say
that it is actually bad
for example if a young child dies and
then goes to heaven
is that actually bad because what if
that child lived a bad life ended up
going to hell
right is that is that now a good thing
for that child to live
and like you can question it you know
until you until the cows come home as
they say but like
at the end of the day you never really
know the full implications so with you
your limited knowledge and your your
bias it's kind of like you cannot
arrive at a a solid conclusion and at
the end of the day as someone who
doesn't believe in god
you have subjective views anyway so you
can't really say that this is
immoral or this is wrong
and it's like science will always play
ketchup but you really want to
bet your life let alone your afterlife
on something that you're not even going
to hear in tito
makes no sense to me and it's like we're
going to get into that later but
everything that the quran says there's
no contradictions in it this is the only
book of faith where there's zero
contradictions and i challenge any of
you guys if you can find any
which you subjectively feel our
contradictions bring to us bring it to
anyone
there's answers out there people if
you're willing to look but it's the only
book of faith where everything that it
says
is true either
i would say 80 of it has been proven to
be true
and then like 28 of it has been proven
to either be true or untrue
but it hasn't been proven yet to be
untrue so therefore it's not untrue
and logically speaking it's like bro 80
is not a bad track record
yeah as zakir naik says um 80 of the
quran is 100 percent true exactly and
the last 20
is ambiguous so just logically speaking
the last
20 would also be 100 true following that
probability
i mean um hell you wanted to say
something
yeah i was gonna say let's let's end it
off here
my brothers first podcast
this went down smoothly
there was actually one more point i
wanted to to make really quickly because
i know it's going to be in the back of
people's heads
so people are going to be like okay so
what like okay
i can or can't believe in god whatever
there's no proof for
or sorry there's no proof against it
maybe you have an argument for it but
some people wouldn't consider it proven
some people are going to ask the very
silly question of
okay well why don't you believe in
unicorns right and they're going to try
and make the comparison that
you know you don't have any proof
unicorns don't exist so on and so forth
but the issue is this is what's called
the fallacy of equivocation you're
trying to make equal
two things that are just not equal god
being
a necessary being for the universe to
even exist
versus a unicorn which is the possible
existence
santa claus which is a possible
existence so on and so forth which
actually santa claus had an origin
right like a mythological origin
with krampus and christmas and all this
stuff pagan pagan uh
ideologies and beliefs so for any of you
who are like well i mean
i don't believe in god for the same
reason i don't believe in unicorns
it's not the same exact thing and it's a
fallacy of a qualification but with that
being said
alhamdulillah i think this was a very
very interesting and productive
first episode so may love blessed both
of you
yeah and for for the viewers
uh this is the first time and uh our
quality
you know inshallah we'll get better over
time
video quality audio quality uh you
already know what it is
so if you're liking the stuff make sure
to subscribe
make sure to like it make sure to share
it
you know this is this is by
and this is the most understatement
thing that i can say right now this is
only the beginning
inshallah inshallah
and last thing last thing my bad for
cutting you off brother
but the last thing i want to say to
people is leave
comments hit us up whether it be through
the comments whether it be through dms
like we're here we may not respond uh
as quick as possible i'm sure romney and
fayette will probably respond to y'all
very quickly
um i can't speak too much for myself but
i will respond at some point or another
uh but yes get to us we're more than
happy to interact and talk about these
things with y'all
yeah guys insha allah look forward to um
future episode this so far was why god
you know it's gonna we're definitely
gonna talk about why islam where islam
comes into this
but in the meantime rami brother and i
know i just had two quick questions for
both of you
imagine your life right now you're
exactly the same
nothing's changed except you're not a
muslim
you're not led by god you don't believe
in god
how do you feel right now what would be
different
you want me to go first bro yeah you
should take it away bro
so are we referring to like right now at
this point in time what we're referring
to like years later
not right now right now um
i'd probably still be trying to look for
something to
complete me in a sense for something to
give me the uh
that final piece of the puzzle to make
me happy to
make me be at ease at peace and
you know just be lost bro
because that's what i was before i was
the definition of loss even though
if someone looks on my channel and looks
at my videos and even if i look
in retrospect and just look at how i
used to live and how i used to think and
i used to feel
like i was lost bro i was doing things
that helped
but ultimately i was lost trying to find
a way
and you know alhamdulillah bro
yeah man where do you see yourself
briefly
being i guess led to
you're bleeding yourself uh
i don't know man only only god knows and
like i said we
we can't connect the dots looking
forward we can only connect them looking
backwards only one that can connect them
looking forward
you know who it is i like that
ramy and honestly i don't even know if i
should answer that question
being completely honest but um yikes man
i mean it really depends not if i wasn't
a muslim
dang man either one
i might still be with my ex or i might
be with someone else
if i'm this is this is why i didn't want
to answer this because honestly
from being completely honest i might not
have even been here
at this point honestly because once like
back you know you guys know what
what i've been through and stuff there's
a really really dark time in my life
where i just didn't want to live anymore
and though like i'm
the only reason i i stopped it in my own
head these thoughts of you know
i never really told myself i want to
kill myself but i kept telling myself i
i just i don't want to be anymore like i
want to die i just want it to happen
but because i was a muslim i i had to
stop it there because we all know if you
kill yourself then like that you go to
hell
and um believing in allah provided a lot
of comfort for me
and it didn't just give me a reason not
to kill myself but actually gave me a
reason to keep living
specifically right because you could be
alive when not living that's why you
know i
decided to go back to school and to
apply to university and to change my
career and
all this stuff alhamdulillah so i
actually i started this podcast with you
guys
um so honestly a part of me wants to say
that if i didn't have allah if i wasn't
muslim i
probably would have just off myself
right there
i would have been about a year ago
subhanallah so
alhamdulillah for islam yeah man
that did not happen bro ultimately
i'm sure i wanna i wanna know where you
will be as well if i have
so before i even say anything why don't
you let us know where you'd be
all right bro uh if i wasn't muslim
i'd say i think i would be 10 times more
lost than it was when i was a muslim but
not a believer
in that i would be i wouldn't even know
what objective morality is i'd be you
know growing up in a society where my
family doesn't have these values which
now i know are right you know most of
them but
i'd be i've been going around you know
believing in santa claus and just living
lives and not being liberated not being
free but man
i think that pain is less because
the greatest problem you can have is not
knowing you've got a problem to begin
with
me becoming a muslim being born a muslim
but not being a believer bro that stage
was worse
because it's almost like i'm living in
this like y'all was the matrix right so
it's almost like i'm living in this blue
pill
world where i don't know what's real i
don't know what's not real
any anything i do which aligns with the
any like red pill truth which in the if
you watch the matrix that's like the
real
it's painful but it's real so when i was
in that stage it's like anything good i
do which aligns with allah aligns with
this on
alignment whatever would be maybe like
just by chance i wasn't doing it because
i knew it was right or whatever
anything i did wrong was obviously out
of ignorance and again me not being led
but it's like once you once you wake up
and see life for what it is and see you
know reality is
you know the truth you make informed
decisions so i'd be doing the opposite
of that
if i was lost and the peace i have now
i can't i can't explain it i can't
compare it to anything else
but a lot guys who he was man and
inshallah all we could do is just keep
praying that allah keeps guiding us
thanks and i'm sure y'all all y'all can
agree
that if if it wasn't for islam if it
wasn't for
allah guiding us we'd all be cucks
like we we would all be cooked by
something in our life whether that be
our woman
whether that be our job whether that be
um
some random person on the street that
just
really makes us pissed off that day or
something like that
but it's like we gotta understand that
we we submit to something at some point
or another
and it's like if you submit to god like
god's not gonna cuck you
god's not gonna cut you so if you're not
if you're not going to submit to god
whatever else you do submit to
guaranteed is going to [ __ ] you
i agree yeah who are we going to say
me no uh oh no because you said i'm
gonna let you
uh answer your question first that's
that's what i was gonna say
[Music]
um as they say everyone's asleep to
something
and the only way to truly be free is to
be a slave to the one who created you
and the one who will who can who's the
only one who's capable of loving you
perfectly
giving you what you need sustaining you
so on and so forth the one with no bias
one with all the information
alhamdulillah if you're a slave to your
own desires i wish you the best
if you're a slave to another person
wishing the best for your slave to money
uh music whatever it is i wish you all
the best because
that is probably in my opinion not the
path you want to be taking because that
will lead you
to unprecedented areas and that will
lead you just ultimately to depression
because you're going to be trying to
find gratification in little things
temporarily and then long term it's
going to [ __ ] you
friends better i agree
boom that right there podcast number two
y'all be on the lookout for that one in
the meantime once you guys put down your
popcorn you guys like this video
you guys hit subscribe you guys look at
our comments maybe find our socials
hit us up for any questions what
do you guys think they should do in the
meantime what do you think they should
think about in the meantime
honestly i would say just reflect on
your views
your values your beliefs see if they are
logically coherent
and question what you believe to begin
with and try and empty
their your glass so to speak as much as
you can and then revisit these points
even
we watch some parts of the podcast and
try and just reflect on them do they
make sense to you
do you have any reason pardon me do you
have any reason not to believe in these
things
and just reflect as a person everybody
has their own journey right no i don't
believe anybody's going to watch this
but okay well i'm muslim now
right it's a process for everyone and
there's no shame in taking
you know the time you need taking too
much time there is shame in that
um if you don't need it and you're
wasting time there are shame in that but
taking the time you need
is perfectly okay that's all i have to
say on that
we're very we're very we identify with
our egos our ego is our identity who we
are
it's so much easier to keep identifying
with it
because we as human beings we run
towards pleasure and we run away from
pain
so we're not gonna like sitting back and
it's it's one thing guys hearing what
we're saying here and being like okay
cool
uh whatever like and then close your
laptop go on
it's another thing truly taking like
forget an hour even 10 minutes
before yourself before bed just like
sitting in bed
not some crazy crazy ish like you know
light up a candle and sit in like some
meditation position i'm not saying that
i'm saying
just close your eyes really reflect
really think like
is what you're doing logical is what
you're doing true to your nature
is what you're doing even in by your
highest definitions of subjectivity
is it right is it purposeful is it
resourceful
is it taking you anywhere are you really
happy these are not
easy questions and it's not not supposed
to be because having a paradigm shift or
an ego death or whatever you want to
call it
to like strip away your identity and
form a new identity
it's not easy like a caterpillar doesn't
just turn into a butterfly
it has to go through all those whatever
life stages that y'all learned in in
school it doesn't just like cocoon
the cocoon bro and it doesn't just turn
from that to like
a butterfly it doesn't just wings don't
just come out it's a stage
a lot of people might be scared like
what is happening i used to look like a
caterpillar now i'm turning
this whole thing is forming what is that
you know and it
i think that parable is very similar to
to us paradoxical but
it's like those in that cocoon
what do they see from the inside just
the shell like they're just they're just
going to resist
everything they're just going to resist
change they're going to resist all these
new ideas coming in they're going to be
like
nah man like i don't see it i can't see
it because from inside the cocoon you
can't see it you gotta break through you
gotta become that butterfly
yep it's gonna hurt and it's gonna hurt
but you gotta go through it it's like we
were talking about the cognitive
dissonance
you gotta be able to disassociate
yourself from your emotions
from your ego see it for what it is
don't try to
uh push it down but just don't get
controlled by it
if not you're just gonna stay stuck in a
cycle and you'll never
get to the truth because you're letting
your emotions dominate you
and because you don't want to feel that
suffering and that pain to get to the
truth
you're essentially taking the blue pill
and you already know you have
two options you can take the red pill
or you can take the blue pill
it's all up to you like there's there's
no there's no right or wrong but you
reap what yourself
you're gonna be responsible and the blue
pill um no one's denying you guys and
we're gonna leave you with this
it is the easy way out let's not let's
not get it twisted like it will make you
i guess it'll go down easier it'll help
you sleep at night it'll come for you
it'll tell you everything you want to
know
it will literally reassure all the
beliefs you have right now
but you can you're living in a fairy
tale it's not real
the red pill though it's hard it's you
know short term
it's going to be brutal but long term
life's going to get so easy and so
peaceful
with the blue pill short term it'll give
you comfort and ease but long term
it's going to give you this ease so you
know it's all up to you
a lot all right with that being said
i think that was a very very productive
episode alhamdulillah i think that was
an amazing way to end it
so to all you watching me allah bless
you all i encourage you all to think
deeply on this and ponder and reflect on
it
take your time you know we're all you
know just
regular people like you guys we're all
we've all been through it right we're
going through it
along with you guys so i ask that you
don't see
any of us uh in any other light other
than we're just your peers
and your brothers so may god bless you
all
i mean and share this video because if
you found it resourceful
here's the thing you guys found our
videos somehow i don't know if it was
through
y'all were following one of us or maybe
you found it on youtube you stumbled
upon it but
it didn't just happen you found it for a
reason and maybe somebody else might
benefit from it too
so share with them watch it together
knows and
look forward to episode